hey guys two days ago the vaynermedia
interns came and spent a half an hour
with me it ended up being about 40
minutes or I don't know actually will
see officially in the time below but it
was it really just clicked and kind of
Alex Campbell I've just kind of looked
at each other and we're like let's put
this out and let's put it out ASAP so if
you're ending your internship or you
have somebody doing an internship or for
next year's internship or just in
general if you're navigating life in the
early stages of the dawn of your career
watch this video I I made a video that
went pretty viral a couple years ago
like I couldn't believe more in like the
people aspect of all this there's
nothing you learned from any but I don't
give a [ __ ] how hands-on or how much you
actually you've done none of it is even
remotely close to as ry+ as like the
people you meet especially you know I
don't know how young or where you guys
are but like if some of you come back
and intern again next year work here or
somewhere else if you're lucky enough to
get into a place like a vaynermedia and
there's many planning we have our unique
cultures and I think things that are
very much an anomaly but let's just talk
about a growing company that's going to
be an industry leader like it's crazy to
me that some of the people you're
working for right now are literally
gonna be the CMOS of the biggest
companies in the world like people just
don't understand how life actually works
and like how actually this all plays out
hey this actually plays out is it's
going to only be about the people like
the skills are commoditized there's a
lot of people that gonna be able to do
what you do but like who you meet and
how they play out and like more
importantly because of the uniqueness of
our company who the people that you're
working with become like do you ever see
those crazy like documentaries were like
Spielberg and Lucas and like [ __ ] you
know all those guys like hung out
together right or like what I grew up in
in Silicon Valley like I would have
dinner and be like Zuckerberg and Travis
remover like like there's moments in
time and an advertising or communication
if that's what you give a [ __ ] about
that moment in time is vaynermedia
people here now lots of these people
will go on and be the CEOs of agencies
or brands
or things of that nature and I could you
know it might be tough at a young age
you might it's tough at an older age
like you may not be extroverted it might
feel weird to say hello but like in your
last week or what have you liked as much
cafeteria time as much like hello as
much as you can like muster up literally
hi um I believe in it the most the high
arm in the elevator like first of all we
have a good culture like it's less scary
to say hello to somebody cold here than
other places I don't think we're perfect
and I you know but like to me I'd want
to legitimately fire anybody who's not
gonna be nice unless they're dealing
with a real tough issue in their life at
that moment where they won't at least
say hey they may be busy or might be shy
or you know might not love to be
interpersonal fine but it's less scary
here to say hello cold in the cafeteria
or you know walking up the stairs in
production or whatever and so couldn't
push you more if you get anything out of
this like that one random hello that
this mustards out could literally be the
whole [ __ ] thing just could just is
actually I think that's my advice and
we've talked about this a little bit in
the Vayner sports stuff like that's my
advice for when you go back to school
like probably my favorite talk I've
given in the last couple years was to
the UF's to the USC football team for
many reasons one Sam Donald went on to
become the Jets quarterback and so we
became friends because of that so that's
awesome but way more was you know I
speak a lot I do this a lot and you can
always tell when you hit a nerve there's
a moment in that USC football talk where
I tell them I'm like you guys are
[ __ ] idiots you think you're so cool
cuz you're on the USC football team
meanwhile 99% of you this is the
highlight of your life 99% of you this
is the apex is it everything after not
making the NFL is gonna be downhill and
you're walking into these [ __ ]
classrooms and 60% of those kids are
gonna go on to do real [ __ ] and you
think you're too [ __ ] cool and you're
putting your beats by dre on and your
[ __ ] hoodie and not looking anybody
in the eye and think you're somebody and
your life is gonna suck [ __ ] for the
next 50 years because you didn't say
hello to the kids sitting next to you
who went on to [ __ ] run Disney
that is the best piece of advice I can
give you like when you go back to school
like say hello to everybody people as
people are the ROI of life so it's cool
that you got like better at analytics or
like real life experience of talking to
a client commodity you would have gotten
at some point anyway whether you can do
it or not cool but like actually
becoming friends with each other in here
like actually not like when the slack
channel dies like everybody in here can
help the other person potentially in a
real significant way you know 80 percent
of you especially if you don't get into
this company we're gonna have jobs you
[ __ ] hate right out of school and the
other person's gonna have something they
like and they could be the one
recommending you in people questions you
can go anywhere by the way like very
specific to your own [ __ ] like please go
anywhere yes yes that's a great question
one that doesn't happen very often and
I'll tell you why it's the same reason
if you look at I don't know how much you
guys have consumed to me or not
all my bravado me cutting people off
like all the things I do
they're very obvious it's cuz I only
stay in the lane of what I know like you
would die like when my wife and I meet
like a new-school couple and we go out
to dinner and like I'm trying to be a
cordial dinner guests and I'm trying to
meet people and they start talking about
a subject matter you'd laugh on how
quiet I can get I'm not interested in
talking about [ __ ] I don't know it
things are very clear to me like making
a decision about my business this is
what I [ __ ] do right so it's not like
I'm always in clarity mode if I don't
know I go through a process like if you
know if emily is having a huge you know
argument with Brian saw and I need to
figure it out and I don't have a feel
cuz a lot of times I do 50 60 % I
already have my assumptions and
knowledge cuz I'm interacting with
people at scale I'll just go through the
process right I'll meet with other
people like but like making decisions
comes
natural to me mainly cuz I'm not scared
of the loss the biggest vulnerability
everybody has here is they're worried
about somebody else's judgment the
reason there is no moment of clarity is
you don't want to jump you don't to jump
because you're worried if you lose what
people gonna say starting with your
parents your friends your contemporaries
my ability to not truly truly care about
other people's opinions has been the
foundation of my happiness I respect
people's opinions I just I just don't
care about their judgment of me I
flip-flopped about project management at
vaynermedia
like so many times and I don't worry if
somebody hears like make a decision or
like you're stupid or like what the [ __ ]
or why are we always change it like go
work at great advertising got it to an
obstacle or challenge
no because I think the subtlety that
people struggle with is I don't care
about buying the Jets I care about
trying to buy the Jets I'm in love with
the process my ROI is the process so the
insurmountable thing is the best part
you know there's also nothing
insurmountable when you really live a
life of like as long as nine people
don't die or get you know diagnosed with
terminal death like sentences everything
else is really [ __ ] simple I you know
I couldn't community for this sinesses
like like some of you may know this
though most of you haven't had the
luxury of getting close to me but like
some that are starting to get close to
me who have been very close to me nobody
leaves that what they see on video is
who I actually am I mean just but that
doesn't bother me like like that will
eventually be exposed or not like people
get close to me that I don't have
control over their opinion I mean
Caleb's gonna really really know me soon
already really really does is somebody
who consumed a lot of my content and the
deltas extraordinary I guess where I'm
going with that is nothing's
insurmountable this is just life like my
fear my kryptonite is like the big one
is my wife driving my kids and getting
hit by a Mack truck and they're dead
like that's like [ __ ] like that's like
am I in a one-year cloud am i in a
forever cloud like I don't have a sense
yet what happens with my great first
true tragedy right for a long time I
feared the [ __ ] out of my parents dying
I'm over that hump maybe I just got
enough time to be frank you know maybe
I'm just so grateful to be 42 and have
like I'm pretty in a good spot like I'm
just in that place I mean I stay really
cry about it now that's been transposed
to my wife and kids right but even that
I'll be honest with you man
to be very frank I don't know how not to
default into gratitude I default into
like what if Lizzy and I weren't able to
have kids and I would have never even
had that time it goes into a very like
my wiring and then my practicing of my
wiring is just like the inability to
dwell I don't think anybody has control
over me I never worry about my family I
never worry about the government the
president any of it I don't dwell I just
think I'm in control so how do you feel
what how does something feel
insurmountable when you know your income
when you know you're in contrivance a
thought like notice like that was even
interesting to me when you know you're
in control like what are you complaining
about fix it you don't like the school
you're going to and your parents made
you go there quit
don't go what's gonna happen you're not
gonna talk to your parents for two years
cool like you'll then talk to them like
my biggest thing right now with youth is
do
what you want because if you're
appeasing your parents you're gonna
resent them and be regretful your whole
life and then you're not gonna actually
have a relationship with your parents I
look at I spend all my time looking at
old people not young people old people
have played and when old people hate
their old parents because they did what
their parents wanted I'm like that's
wrong [ __ ] it
have the problems now with your parents
for 24 36 48 months and then here's the
good news then it's merit if you were
right that you're actually a rapper not
a lawyer if you became a successful
rapper they're gonna be proud as [ __ ] if
you don't well then guess what they were
right at least that you weren't a rapper
maybe you're still not a lawyer but the
merit of the game will play out to many
people in their youth want both they
want to claim that their parents are
full of [ __ ] or this is wrong but they
don't want to take the jump into what
they claim and so you want both you want
a [ __ ] on the establishment but you're
not willing to take the risk to prove if
you're good enough then you're full of
[ __ ] not bad yeah but it's super easy
out here once it gets quiet brother once
you can't hear anything it gets super
easy out here
what's the number one piece of advice
you wish you had done when you were our
age or something that you would have
done differently
I probably could have enjoyed my 20s a
little more like I don't think you guys
understand how real my propaganda of my
youth is I did nothing but worked like
all of you all of you had more fun this
weekend than I had between eighteen and
twenty nine that's weird so I think I
went too far the other way you know like
an Ibiza or Coachella would have
probably been good for me none of that
exists for me you know but I think I
don't regret it because it's my truth
but in hindsight like nothing is good
when it's out of balance and like I was
a hundred and seven like I literally
lost all my friends like not out of like
loss because I'm a good guy and they're
good and it was nice but like with there
was no modern technology there was no
smart phone and so like I just [ __ ]
checked out and just worked in a liquor
store for a decade without putting up my
head you think that helped get to where
you are now a hundred percent and do you
think well to answer her question I used
to think that but now in hindsight I do
think one [ __ ] weekend or even one
week in the summer probably in hindsight
wouldn't have changed the outcome but at
the time I didn't think that and so if I
would do something different I would
have taken one trip but I'm talking one
trip like I worked you know retail is
weird I worked the weekends like
whenever was like like everyone's here
like all what a tough week I'm like what
if you had to work all day Saturday and
that was the most intense day because
that's what it was in retail that was
the day right and suntanned because I
worked like 7:00 a.m. to like 11:00 p.m.
Sunday was like sleep in like I
literally woke up at like 10:30 11 12
and like hung out with AJ you know like
like like even like you know one of
things I regret is in essence how I
treated the two girls I dated the most
during that time because it was just
literally like checking the box to have
companionship because it was just like
100% business
you know so but at the same token the
reason I don't talk a lot about that is
I think everybody else all of you for
example all of you are way too far any
other Delta if you have substantially
ambitions if you don't that's cool like
my own thing always is like if you want
to make a hundred thousand a year have
great work-life balance like cool but
like too many kids are talking right now
about billionaire and millionaire and
crushing it and dominating and just
nowhere close to putting in the pieces
of training themselves for what it's
gonna take you know I don't think people
understand what a 1% life means it means
1% actions to your point you have to
sacrifice a lot and by I don't think
that's right I think it's right for me
because it was my calling it was in my
head every minute you have to be
self-aware but I think part of
self-awareness is not to talk [ __ ] you
know about what you're gonna do because
then you're putting yourself in you've
got to back up your actions one of the
biggest reasons I want kids to talk less
[ __ ] is cuz they're putting themselves
into a [ __ ] trap you're talking a big
game everybody heard it now you feel the
social pressure to deliver on it but you
don't have the [ __ ] chops or the
willingness or appetite to actually do
it which I think then just needs one
great you know blog post or video or you
know piece of content that makes you
admit that I don't think you're in a
trap you just have to acknowledge it
nice hey Jay do this for a whole group
that's awesome
that makes me happy was talking like old
war stories yes a lot actually so I
actually would disagree with AJ I don't
think our age gap was the driver
I think empathy and compassion and true
love over money is really that being
said it probably didn't hurt because it
probably allowed him even though he's
competitive and alpha-2
maybe concede certain things to me
because of how far along I was and where
I could rely really always played the
one a to his one be for real unlike the
friction my dad and I had where we both
tried to be two cooks in a kitchen
so I played both I know what it looks
like to have consensus of partners and
not so I've got a lot of context for it
AJ told me a lot actually and which so I
think I've evolved quite a bit in being
more having more radical candor and
shooting it straight I'm so positive
that I don't like confrontation and
negativity which I think led to me
handling a lot of things wrong in my
youth where I wasn't I would try to like
I feel like if I you know the cliche
thing like the girl trying to turn
around the bad boy and that's like the
kind of boy she likes I feel like I have
that gear too I feel like I'm always on
a charity case or like if somebody's not
good enough like I'm gonna help them or
if they work at Vayner they'll be
happier and more successful and I've
brought enough shoulders to create that
environment because they won't be
successful out there without me and I
think I miss played that and I think AJ
is a very straight shooter and watching
him manage that closely it rubbed off on
me I think AJ also back to the earlier
question is dramatically more into
smelling the roses and enjoying success
and having some sort of work-life
balance you know and I think that rubbed
off on me as well a little bit during
our time together
uh you know another thing that stands
out is that really work then it's
probably why I you know I wish you guys
could feel the way I feel towards you I
was such a whiz kid that I respected AJ
from day one like just cuz he was
straight at a school I thought his
opinion carried as much weight and so it
wasn't necessarily what he taught me it
was being together it taught me that
that's right and like like we except in
sports that you could be LeBron and Kobe
but we don't in business one of the
reasons your internship is allowing you
some freedom to do [ __ ] and I know some
of you did it like I know there's a
delta some of you did a ton of ton of
[ __ ] you know I can't control 900 people
every second but why why there's a
culture more here of like compared to
some of your friends who are like really
you're doing [ __ ] like I'm [ __ ] like
just sitting here like [ __ ] playing
on [ __ ] you know who the [ __ ] anyway
is because of that respect for maybe
you're good enough to run my company
right now like talent is talent and so
but candor smelling roses stand out
since you're constantly filming and
releasing new content and it's always so
positive and inspiring does anything
ever happen in your home or work life
that like puts you in a fog and you have
to like pull yourself out of it it's a
building and like spreading your message
I would never I would never film if I
wasn't in the right place I don't power
through theirs I mean you couldn't wrap
your head around how much bad [ __ ]
happens every day to me and this company
and like that's that's actually the job
my job is eating [ __ ] you know like
everything's on me ultimately right yeah
I mean I'm sure of course I get into
funks you know but I've tremendous
perspective and like my like I have no
sustained funk like even the thought of
like a day is out of question like a
full day of being in a funk is just not
gonna happen
it just can't like there's just nothing
that can happen that makes me change my
mindset of like how good we have it I
mean if you actually understand oh this
but just looking around the room the
fact that you're sitting in a building
in New York City in America and have an
internship here you would probably [ __ ]
your pants if you if there was a world
ranking on quality of life happiness
like just net score of where do you rank
on earth like a new system came out it
took everything into account it brain
scanned you for happiness depression all
of it what is your net rank in the world
you would be humbled by how good your
life is I don't think you have a
perspective I don't think anybody does
and I'm not even sure I do I just try my
best to think about this kind of almost
daily where do you rank out of seven
point seven billion people the answer
for a lot of you is outrageously high if
you're a white dude in here and your
family has any kind of financial
security
you're an outerspace
outer [ __ ] space that's humbling and
then for me that's kind of like the data
but then again what isn't taken to
account at all in society is like cool
your white dude with a family that's
like to me having too much is the is the
really the other play like what we don't
have is a read on people's mental health
right and so I know have that too so now
I'm just like you know I can't get into
a funk it's almost inappropriate you
know not that I force it it's just
become me you know how many of you work
out pretty religiously think about when
you didn't think about when you started
and think about how it now it feels
completely foreign not to that's what I
do mentally like just [ __ ]
contextualize your problem and let me
give you a really good piece of ice pay
very close attention to who's listening
to you complain it's a very important
tell like I would [ __ ] on you if you
complain to me so pay close attention
because when it's your mom or it's
another friend that complains all the
time you're in a bad system
in terms of like judgments and criticism
where's the line of taking something as
constructive
something and then just others I being
like going with your gut and
I'd like you to be a hell of a lot more
closer to glowing with their gut and not
listening to them especially at this age
at this age you kind of almost have to
see it through to see how right or wrong
you are there's more upside and you
figuring out if you're right or wrong
you can always take everybody's feedback
in your 30s you know look most people
are just gonna make assumptions just
based on your age they're just giving
you feedback for the sake of feedback
cuz you're 20-something now if it's
something like math and it's black and
white you get to the wrong answer they
were right like like you know but like
but like the people here in analytics
and media like that's like math and like
you could [ __ ] have any ego you want
but if like it played out wrong you lost
which is what's great about it it's very
like black and white but all the other
stuff is very gray and becomes very
subjective the great foundation of my
life is being undereducated it really
works for me just don't just don't have
that gear of seeing the world the same
way
do you ever get stressed I almost wonder
if like what ended up happening was you
know when you're a 22 year old kid and
you walk into a family business and you
explode it in year one and now from day
they're on at 23 you're the foundation
of the financial success of your entire
family and you're the emotional pillar
of your family along with your mother so
you're both financially and emotionally
responsible for everything you love at
23 you almost go into the other play I
almost feel like I've been in in stress
in perpetuity then it's become happiness
I don't know what else to say you know I
don't feel stress I don't judge myself I
feel like I'm trying I know what my
intent is I feel like I'm trying really
hard and like my big thing is like
before you say something to me like why
don't you look at yourself like it's
really hard for me to get going like you
know like man what I love for all of you
to be empowered with like when your
parents say something to call them out
on them doing the same thing that's what
parents do they impose their thing on
you they're reak your mom is doing what
her mom did to her even though she hated
that her mom did it to her it's how
humans work anyway
probably I'd I'm a big fan of like
sleeping in the bed that you've made I
got big ambitions I'm trying to be out
here doing [ __ ] well guess what nobody
should be crying for me and so I can't
complain I'm [ __ ] put myself out
there right like I'm putting myself out
there I don't have to say yes to the
interview so I don't have to [ __ ] be
filming my [ __ ] self 24 hours a day
I made this bed I got to sleep in it
everything comes along with it and if I
do something [ __ ] stupid or wrong and
I get called out on it I need to own
that [ __ ] and I'm okay with that because
I don't think I'm perfect I'm just
trying to say narrow you narrow is my
thing you know stain my lien you know so
I don't talk to you know a lot of people
you don't talk about politics I'm like I
want to do homework on it I don't want
to just shoot my opinion
like like you know I've got opinions but
like now like I just think about all
those things are about anything anything
I need to be thoughtful I stay very
narrow chess two moves I do so many
things that are actually setting up
something else but I get scrutinized
judged or viewed on the first move
a jab isn't trying to knock somebody out
in a fight I'm really good at jabbing
I'm really thoughtful I'm playing long
game
I'd love to hear from your perspective
like when you read what someone had to
say about what it was like to work here
and work for you it's the best thing in
the worst thing that's was ever set I
mean in the most extremes it's like I'm
devastated I'm leaving it's because of
some outrageous circumstance like my
parents are sick or my significant
others getting transferred and like this
is breaking my heart and soul I want to
work here forever and in the other
direction is this whole thing is full of
[ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
I've been undermined all you you're
completely full of [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you you're full of [ __ ] those are the
best and worst yeah it's super tough but
what what ends up happening back to
stress or this and that it's I've
empathy by the way they might be right
like I'm not crippled by the fact that
three people right now could be terrible
and like serendipitously got teamed up
created a triangle of terror and I
haven't been able to like weed it out
yet the best part is though I don't want
that look you were in the meeting where
I literally told the entire team like
from now on anytime somebody's crying
somewhere I need to know on the moment
it happens you saw it not for show for
the intern you were in the meeting
that's who I am
like like so like I sleep well at night
triangle of terror and somebody says I'm
a piece of [ __ ] and this is all a facade
I can live with that because I
understand that could be true for
offices 900 people even though I'm in
the pulse of every minute I'm trying out
here but like I'm not [ __ ] you know
like omnipresent you know and so so I
just feel great with my intent in my
efforts I know I'm not making financial
decisions like 99.9% of course I am
because we have to make payroll but I'm
not trying to like maximize profits so I
can buy a helicopter and feel good about
myself and so like I just know I'm Way
ahead of everything else and I read all
that stuff I read every one of those you
know I get them right away I [ __ ] we
talk about I don't read [ __ ] I read
every word I try to synthesize it I
email every one of them which is why we
have their non vein or email I try to
could you know like let them know that
I'm here for them in perpetuity if
anybody ever works I've been it for you
guys
just being an intern if I can help you
in 19 years you email me be like I was
an intern and [ __ ] 2018 and then like
you know like now my aunt wants to be at
this thing you know I don't give a [ __ ]
like just feel free to reach out and so
intent Trump's a lot you have to execute
on your intent you know a lot of my
closest friends kind of scrutinized like
intent intent you could intend to be a
good guy but shoot somebody with a gun
and then I'm like I get it but usually
intent maps to your actions and so I
[Music]
want legacy it's very insular it's not
from somebody else you know my
inspiration is I'm aware that something
really good happened when I was produced
and I want to see it through I think I
owe it to my parents I think I owe it to
I'm just very driven by gratitude I'm
very inspired by it I know good things
happen mentally really this you know and
I need to see it through I you know
there's a curiosity of how big can this
be that really [ __ ] with me in a good
way like I really really really think
I'm gonna be Oprah
like for real which is amazing like a
singular individual for a moment in time
you know it's really interesting to to
me like and I think about psycho like I
analyze a lot of things I'm like if I'm
right and this happens in nine years
it's gonna be an interesting time like
in a world where like white dudes are
like demonized and things of that nature
like is it important that like I think
about tough like the fact that I'm
penetrating 15 to 25 year old dudes and
I'm pushing empathy and kindness like is
this all meant to be you know I get into
that I definitely do I'm like I'm such
an alpha male yet like what I preach is
so traditionally soft and like you I get
to live my life like I get to be like in
an airport and see like a hood dude roll
up to me be like yo gratitude dawg you
know it's like you know it's like it's
fun it's like I'm seeing the Peace of
them seeing the puzzle come together Wow
being unbelievably
comfortable in my capitalistic you know
ambition you know I think I'm a very
funny read even to my site as I read
myself it's like I've got all this
underlining stuff but the thing that
most people know is like he wants to buy
the Jets which is very like douchey and
like the whole thing's super interesting
to me and I'm always like am i
sandbagging everybody like is that what
I put out like is that why I speak that
way like why is it that they like me
more as they get closer not for it like
it's all very interesting to me I see my
patterns
it's the underdog thing you know like
why will I turn on like a golf match
give a [ __ ] but like whoever's the
underdog that's who I'm for like [ __ ]
Mac conference college basketball game
at night turn on underdog right like
Kobe Hatem last season washed-up love
them like I'm very like am I doing that
to myself like do I like the fact that
everybody in the ad world like at age
never covers us they covered us today
about [ __ ] embargoing for snacks
that's a dig that's a razz but like I
love that like I need that I'm driven by
being underestimated and then I think oh
[ __ ] I must be sandbagging myself my
team gets so mad at me they're like why
don't you talk about being smart you
know like I talk about working hard my
propaganda is like my selfie at 4:00 in
the morning looking like [ __ ] on the way
the airport it's not my thoughtfulness
of like 20 years of being right about a
ton of [ __ ] so I don't know like it's
fun to analyze myself for myself but I
try not to do it too much because I'm
always worried of like becoming a
caricature of myself which i think is a
very dangerous move and so that's why I
rely so much on intuition cuz I don't
even want to allow myself to think too
much because I don't want it right I
speak my truth you saw that day with
like the MLB and like I will always
speak my truth and I'll curse and I'll
dress down and I'll let the world come
to me got it
the world came to me when I was your age
this everything I've done was
unacceptable bad at school casual dress
for respect cursing at scale in public
all unacceptable still kind of weirdly
unacceptable but a lot less than it was
it doesn't it's the great vulnerability
ego is just a dress for insecurity ego
is very different than confidence ego is
the manifestation of insecurity I'm very
confident but not blindly you know and I
also like I said something once somebody
tweeted about this weekend and it really
is my biggest truth I genuinely think
I'm gonna be all-time special like I
live my life as in like what kind of
statues are they gonna put up being dead
[ __ ] serious at the same token I
equally believe like the day I die it
could be a non-event or I'll get like 24
hours on social and people tell their
stories of what I did for them and then
it's over so having this hardcore push
and pull of like being all time and
insignificant at the same time is a
balance that's super important and I
don't think ego allows you to do that
ego is I'm insecure let me peacock and
make pretend it's bullying I [ __ ]
hate it
Oh what is working with Ryan and Mary
key giving you like what if they open
your eyes - um well first it's given me
like enormous ambition for the kind of
companies I want to buy because their
working relationship is tremendous like
just kindness and cute and nice and
perfect like real good I haven't spent a
lot of time really digging in like the
publishing world add a sense for it's
not that lateral to me it's just
watching a good kindness leadership team
Ryan is I would argue is a byproduct of
how I think about the world like my
ambition is that more CEOs are like Ryan
caring but alpha and all that but
nothing stands out I haven't spent that
much time with them either and that's
just the truth there's nothing you know
I don't want to say nothing because I
don't want them have their feelings hurt
but it's pretty close to nothing so far
does that ever you know get to you in a
way and I know sometimes you do respond
so what's the why do I respond yeah
serendipity like I'm in a mood you know
like just like I'm just truthfully I
think it's funny I think it's funny I
just think it's funny they like pick
some first of all what I love that I do
is a lot of people razz on people but
they like dark out their account like I
just I'm like look if you're publicly
saying this I'm gonna publicly put you
on blast I think that's funny
not much like like I listen brah Matt
who the [ __ ] is time to watch
eighty-seven hours of my content to have
a better feel of who I actually a.m. so
that they're grounded in a good opinion
and I know what I'm putting out there
like if you see one [ __ ] video on
Instagram and I'm
acting confident and peacocking because
I'm pissed about somebody who's being a
bully but it looks like I'm being a
bully because I'm cursing and being
alpha like that's it that's all you need
like if you brought up in a household
where cursing was bad
you don't like me if you like first of
all everybody in the advertising
industry that's living in the old world
by default has to be worried about me
and doesn't like me like I have empathy
to watch something or ultimately why
people guys think about the makeup the
mental makeup of somebody who takes time
out of their life to leave a negative
comment about somebody else do you know
how sad I feel for them in the history
of my life to the day I go in the grave
I would never do that why it's a
complete waste of time I'm in a place
where I need to comment negatively and
try to tear somebody down with my three
minutes firstly you have to consume the
content to get a thought second you have
to like have that in you that you think
that's a good idea do you much pain
you're in when you leave the negative
comment do you know how [ __ ] up you
are macro I'm never worried about
anybody who's dragging people down there
weakest [ __ ] and most people think
they're strong because it allowed I mean
they're so weak you started when you
were 14 don't like reading writing how
do you prove marriage not you personally
and how when you were younger how we
prove don't dude I got [ __ ] on like [ __ ]
when oh you don't merit only gets proven
on the field like if you spent as much
time thinking about how to gain respect
into putting all that energy into
actually executing to get the respect
you'd be in a totally different place I
didn't I just took my punches dude the
level of judgment I had at your age I
was going to Mount Ida College which
literally went out of business this year
I went to Mount Ida college which nobody
had ever heard of and still haven't I
worked at my dad's liquor store at this
point in my life getting into any
argument that I'm gonna be good or just
didn't even cross my mind I just worked
and got better at my craft you're
spending too much time justifying
instead of executing you're having
arguments with yourself first then your
parents then the people closest to you
don't just go do your literally debating
the outcome of a game in the national
anthem part you're just you're you're
worried you're just you're valuing other
people's opinions don't you have to earn
it
you have a nerd [ __ ] yet I guess you
could be a prospect a lot of first picks
overall [ __ ] suck so I don't you know
way too much like a social commentary
and [ __ ] pontificating about
something that hasn't happened yet and
like listening to somebody else's
playbook is ridiculous especially
somebody who played it 25 or 35 years
ago your parents opinion is stunningly
bad
they're awesome like I've notice though
or maybe they're terrible I don't know
but nonetheless it's completely not
practical they're utterly incapable of
projecting the context of the playing
field that you're playing in and like
the biggest fear I have is that half of
you are gonna pander to it because
they're gonna financially subsidize your
opening act your pandering to it because
you want a better apartment out the gate
and so parents are gonna pay for it thus
you feel a subconscious need to appease
them in the short term see this is not
just a parent's game that's what's fun
to think this is [ __ ] you there's a
really great way to like eliminate your
parents leverage get off their payroll
I don't agree with my parents about
anything or everything I'd never even
[ __ ] value their opinion enough I got
off their payroll and [ __ ] put them
on my payroll
you know and not really cuz you know I
think that's a little douchey but like I
came in the game and [ __ ] right away
contributed and paid them back for
everything they've ever done for me it
was just never in that place the bit you
know it's real fun in here like haha
everybody who's gonna watch I'm like
[ __ ] on your parents until you
realize you're [ __ ] full of [ __ ] you
should you should have no respect until
you actually execute it you could have
reading point you could again back to
sports it's good you can have a
reputation but like first of all your
entire academic career is horseshit
compared to what you're about to go into
give a [ __ ] about what you've done in
school it's got zero mapping to the
reality of what you're about to do so
that's one and then to get off their
payroll fake environments and they want
you on their payroll if they can afford
it because then they have control then
you can do the things that makes them
feel good to say to their friends you
wanna be happy get off your parents
payroll it's much more fun to take the
subway and have three shitty roommates
than to be psychologically controlled by
your parents [ __ ] I like that Caleb
that's the clip right there
no really I like this first time I've
said it that way that really makes sense
to me
that's the biggest issue right now
everyone's posturing
what did you do to gain emotional
intelligence I don't know man like my
mom has it so I took her DNA she gave it
to me so that's good uh you know i think
i think adversity is the foundation of
success and i think my whole childhood
was had adversity i didn't speak the
language i wasn't physically a menace i
you know i was terrible at school like i
feel like by the time i kind of like hit
the game it was all upside like the
reason i couldn't hear anybody anymore
was cuz what they were saying wasn't
super interesting so i said [ __ ] it i'll
just but I
but even you know what's funny I'm
painting a false picture it never
bothered me I do think there was a
little bit of a natural emotional
intelligence foundation there but I will
say practice like I do believe in that I
definitely have evolved I'm struggling
to deconstruct it and which is why I
don't talk about it a lot but like I do
think I've said one or two things here
that maybe helped one or two of you but
I think he literally repeated like
living in a shitty apartment with three
people I hate and taking the subway
is better than being emotionally
controlled by my parents may make you
not take unlimited uber from your
parents when you get out of school no
thank you
I don't know I think that's cool
accountability is really attractive
intuitively and specifically meaning I
don't judge myself so like if I miss my
daughter's recital because Kraft wants
to give us ten million dollars I'm gonna
miss it and I'm I don't give a [ __ ]
meaning I don't give a [ __ ] of people
judging me on what the current state of
proper politically correct parenting is
because like I don't know I love my dad
with all my heart and didn't see him the
first 15 years of my life there's a
million ways to do it and that my intent
is there I always try to make everything
you know but then purposefully like I'm
really excited that I'm taking these
three weeks off in August every year it
worked like the world checks out these
kind of two weeks three weeks in August
and in Christmas and I'm hacking and I'm
always thinking about new things and
just trying to find new ways to spend
more time and you know I felt like I was
winning and then felt I'd needed a
little extra boost so started doing like
half-day Friday not half day but like a
half day six getting home at 6:00 p.m.
on Friday my half day just trying you
know just trying trying to communicate
with more and more which I think is
something we've gotten a little bit
better out of the last half year effort
um here's what happens if you listen to
this whole talk when you actually don't
value anybody else's opinion but your
own then you just spend all your time on
trying to make the things you believe in
better the reason that I wanted to
intern at vaynermedia is because I see
it as like a pioneer in the advertising
industry and I'm like all for
advertising that's what I'm passionate
about it's awesome um so how long do you
think it's gonna take for the industry
to evolve my intuition is it will really
gain momentum when the economy collapses
there's no reason for them to do it now
veiners model is is just not accepted
thus doesn't allow for us to get all the
dollars we get but I think people are
starting realize we're too big for it to
not have merit and I definitely think
I'm inspiring the next generation to
build their own shops that look more
like it
so I think in a decade there'll be a lot
more acceptance to what we're doing how
are we doing in time five minutes ago 15
minutes um this is fun
one last question if you don't care
about anybody's opinion that's the last
question it becomes much easier to ask
yes okay not not that's I think that's a
great question for a lot of other people
that just doesn't come natural to me
like what like every piece of
informations literally on your phone and
then like learning process every
organization has its own process you'll
learn more in the first week of wherever
the [ __ ] you go then you will like
listen I'm not trying to [ __ ] on school
like especially because I think people
like look if you guys want to work at
Boston consulting in this building you
better [ __ ] get your grades up go to
grad school go to [ __ ] Stanford or
Harvard that's how you get into McKinsey
right if you want to be a doctor like
you need to learn the craft but like for
most of us if I mean my biggest piece of
advice is to meet as many people and
make significant relationships like
friends like for real and enjoy the last
vacation that looks like this in your
life it's a [ __ ] vacation like I
would enjoy it like so many of you are
gonna stress out your last two years
thinking it's gonna be an indicator to
your life just don't fail out I think
that's my rally cry just don't fail like
if you really think in 2018 that your
grade point average swing of one or two
points let let alone point something
have any indication on how your life is
gonna play out
you're [ __ ] lost
like skip a class and let go like listen
to a reading by somebody at the Barnes &
Nobles while they're still open an hour
away you know yeah just don't fail out
like I don't really what do you think
like help me like educate me like what
are you learning in class that you think
is real especially like even like week
one like you said like with all my media
professors I'm like you think that
applies like 10 20 years ago it's like
not current they made me memorize a
graph of course it's fun as [ __ ] yeah I
like being with people that are my age
of course people that understand me too
but guess what else you can do with
40,000 you could go to every single
[ __ ] music festival on earth like
like this whole notion of propaganda of
like but it's the people sure why don't
you give me back the [ __ ] 40k and why
don't I [ __ ] go to Coachella and
Ibiza and to [ __ ] Austria like you
can hang out with kids your age in
perpetuity that [ __ ] that last
[ __ ] frontier that college is [ __ ]
trying to sell everybody on like but you
grow up and you get to be with your
people and you meet lifelong friends
like give me 40k I'll [ __ ] make it
way better for you you know much more
fun it is to go to like the Dominican
Republic 4,000 people deep for 3,000
bucks for a week you can do so like that
they're gonna lose that game somebody
like I'm a do it myself
some entrepreneur sure he's gonna come
along and start a company and be like
yeah cool let me let me let me set this
up or like what we work and some of
these co-working spaces are doing
they're just setting at like the campus
replication is super easy and a hell of
a lot more like you can learn a lot more
like let me send all of you like a
hundred fifty deep to Peres to France to
work a harvest in the vineyards and like
every three days go into Paris and just
like [ __ ]
I'm with you I agree but that is the
last reason that college should stay up
and be able to do the purple [ __ ]
they're doing and right now it's the
leading [ __ ] ROI you can play for
tonight together somewhere else but give
me 40k each and I'll [ __ ] have you
playing with ninja every night it's so
[ __ ] bro but that being said I'm on an
ideological execution now you're in it
you're not going anywhere so to that
point make it more than seven people
that are your friends to your point
everyone's like I love that unlike you
have nine friends like you really want
to take advantage of like oh it's
awesome campus life like culture we can
go like serendipity like then do
something about it instead of what
everyone's doing which is in your
[ __ ] clique of six like really
[ __ ] break that like that was always
the best thing that I had I like nine
different friend groups that like made
no sense that like never let me get
popular enough and like was very weird
and like what like people are so
confused by me best thing I did how many
of you were collecting debt for college
tell truth that's okay just curious that
to me is like the thing that I'm
spending my whole life trying to figure
out go ahead yeah colleges new guys
College is [ __ ] new in 1940 which is
five minutes ago not everybody's [ __ ]
dream was to go to college
I don't know but I know it's in trouble
you know like this conversation was not
happening 10 years ago when the economy
collapses on the back of all the college
debt that all of you are occurring and
everybody blames the racket of college
for it
it'll be like banks or other things the
brand will be so bad the conversation
will change and I do believe that you
will be the generation of parents that
don't force your kids to go to college
so I think 30
I think Stanford Harvard I think the top
17 will be able to hold on a little bit
longer just on brand but I think the
really good schools like the state
schools like kind of that upper-middle I
think they're very vulnerable Michigan
is an amazingly good school but
collecting two hundred thousand in debt
with that interest rate for a good solid
Michigan degree in the real life the day
after no way yeah I try to I try to
filter it and try to understand
pay attention who's giving you the
advice what's their KPI
like why are they doing it good I guess
I kind of like addresses it I was gonna
say like doesn't that kind of let your
ego take like the wheel and kind of like
where's like the humility and like how
do you self reflect like say maybe
they're right maybe like I could improve
he gives me his opinion I do something
else I don't necessarily think I'm right
I just would rather die on my own sword
right like that make sense right like I
don't know like actually I think it's
enormous humility it's because I don't
value my own opinion why would I value
yours but I'm gonna do what I want to do
because if it's wrong it's much more fun
to blame myself than to blame you guys
when it ends up being wrong you're gonna
blame your parents and then that gets
really
so I think it's about accountability
humility I don't tell you your opinion
cuz I don't value mine I'm gonna do me
and when I lose I'm like you're a
[ __ ] idiot and when it works I'm like
yeah makes sense right that's where it
comes down to I think it's actually the
review no to all these things look are
the reverse you know it looks like ego
it's actually massive humility I don't
even value my own so you're valuing
yours but then you're valuing someone
else's I don't value either and just go
and then like deal with it after the
fact and when you know you're intense
good like I just want to be happy don't
you want to be happy like happy is not
about money or awards or recognition
it's about just knowing yourself guys
I'm cool if you thought that I thought
the apex of my coolness was gonna be at
42 you've got another thing coming like
there was no indication that
entrepreneurship was gonna be cool
there's no [ __ ] scenario that I
thought would be DMing me yesterday that
doesn't that doesn't play out in the way
that I saw a businessman playing out I
just stayed [ __ ] true the whole time
and then it [ __ ] worked out I really
believe in that [ __ ] listen to yourself
please listen to yourself YouTube leave
a comment below
I'm dying dying for your insight on what
you just saw what stood out give me some
time stamps what stood out
you